merci le jeune homme de 23 ans a fui un
contrôle de police
lors de son interpellation selon lui il
aurait été frappé et insulté par deux
policiers puis lors de la fouille au
commissariat l'un des policiers lui
auraient demandé de se déshabiller de
baisser son caleçon puis de se retourner
l'un des policiers lui auraient alors
introduit un doigt dans le rectum une
fois en cellule le jeune homme affirme
que les fonctionnaires sont venus
narguer à plusieurs reprises après 48
heures de garde à vue il sera à
l'hôpital dans son rapport le médecin
relève des blessures à différents
endroits et une lésions anales
le jeune homme dépose plainte quelques
jours plus tard et prélèvements adn ont
été réalisés au niveau du rectum pour
déterminer si le jeune homme a bien été
victime d'un viol de leur côté les
policiers ont déposé plainte pour
outrage et rébellion
merci à tommy d'être avec nous merci
tommy gilles verdez sûr vous avez suivi
la sphère la semaine dernière ça fait
énormément parler c'est une affaire
énorme avec un témoignage très structuré
de tomic et en plus à un recueilli tout
ça il a eu tout sur procès verbal il a
été à l'hôtel dieu et c'est vrai que son
témoignage qu'on va écouter fait fait
froid dans le dos la police des polices
a d'ailleurs été saisi de la faire
tellement ça va loin alors tommy qui
souhaite garder l'anonymat comme vous le
voyez le 5 avril dernier vous êtes suivi
en voiture par la police oui alors
pourquoi ils vous arrête dans un premier
temps harry vient de micro atomique
bonsoir je vous remercie de me recevoir
ici on laisse la parole à tout le monde
et on aura bien sûr l'autre version dans
les prochains jours dans demain ou après
mais vraiment on est ce important ici
que tout le monde ait la parole et qu'on
est votre témoignage ce soir merci
thomas j'étais arrêté le panda par les
policiers parce que j'ai refusé
d'arrêter les policiers procédaient à un
contrôle d'accor jusque là donc pourquoi
vous refusez de vous arrêter
j'ai refusé parce qu'on en fait moi j'en
problème en comptant les conjoints et
sublime usurpation d'identité
en 2016 j'ai porté plainte à chaque fois
que je sors le thé en conduisant
je suis systématiquement emmené au
commissariat
je pense plus meurt deux heures parfois
24 heures et à la longue c'est souvent
pour moi c'est à dire vous avez une
usurpation d'identité en après votre
pari conduire avec elias est une
personne qui tue
etc est en infraction tu as enfin thion
et depuis je n'ai plus de permis de
conduire ans lorsque j'ai bien prouver
aux policiers où aimé satomi alors déjà
pour contrer ça déjà les policiers
peuvent pas le savoir donc ça c'est
normal qui vous arrête si vous arrête
c'est vrai que les contrôles de police
sas et voilà c'est courant on est obligé
de s'arrêter donc là vous comprenez qu'à
ce moment là ils vouvoient ne pas vous
arrêter à mon avis ils ont dû se dire
curieux qui ne s'arrête pas donc vous
finissez par vous arrêter
les policiers ne sont entrés dans
adacore en voiture en voiture
d'accord sur le montant que vous avez
vous quand vous avez fait la police
il ya eu un jeu refusé m'arrêter pendant
plusieurs mois d'accord les policiers
une fois que j'étais à l'arrêt mais son
entrée dans par derrière à ce moment là
moi j'étais jugé gérable mais quand j'ai
ouvert la porte d'un véhicule j'ai sorti
maman je me suis laissé interpeller les
deux premiers rapports avec les
policiers directement et plus était seul
dans le véhicule
j'étais seul dans le véhicule d'accord à
ce moment là j'ai passé toute l
interpellation j'ai sorti ma main je me
suis de se faire l'intervention a dû
être musclé parce que forcément quand il
ya des délits de fuite comme ça les
interventions sont plutôt musclé parce
que l'élève forcément là la police
israël c'est pareil c'est pas sûr
qu'elle va tomber oui d'autant que tommy
selon nos informations la voiture que
vous conduisiez était une voiture de
location et elle été volé mais vous ne
le saviez pas est ce que c'est vrai ça
soit seront d'accord ce n'est qu'en ce
moment la chantre de parler il fallait
par les policiers fines ozone je pose
aucune résistance
je l'espère il doit directement ça
commence il est insulté morts on va t il
j'ai tué ma mère c'était vraiment
réduction mois sur mais moi je l'espère
veulent aucune résistance à ce moment là
je finis dans le véhicule de police qui
a accidenté je n'étais je pas assez dans
sur la banquette arrière sur mesure où
le nez la sanction de ces cultures
france et laurent sato mis à part les
insultes joly qui vous menottes
si vous avez fait un délit de fuite je
pense nicolas pernikoff sait faire c'est
normal mais c'est vrai que les insultes
bon voilà ça c'est voilà
il ya eu des insultes à caractère
raciste on a très peu de farah à
plusieurs reprises et en fait quand
charme dans le véhicule de police
tant mieux le premier policier procédait
à un contrôle évitent ce que j'ai dans
les pages il prend ma carte d'identité
il voyait directement qui fait issus de
banlieues qui j'ai des origines arabes
et delà des insultes à caractère raciste
et x à la suite c'est sale arabe et a
rien à faire en france on rentre chez
toi alors qu'ils allaient ma carte
d'identité française
dakar est à ce moment-là géant policiers
qui l'ont été dans le coffre
c'est le dernier véhicule et 5008 il ya
un policer sont à gauche est la police
et qui ont été dans le coffre
à ce moment là le policier qui se remet
à gauche m'insulte à répétition mais
j'ai préparé j'ai fait pas attention
d'accord lpj c'est quelqu'un entre dans
le coffre il était monté dans le coffre
pour m'étrangler
c'est à dire dans les cinq minutes ils
seront ils sont vraiment grand
le 4 est vraiment grande policier maître
anglais une geek je dois mourir tu es
mort témoin le policier qui était sur ma
gauche il a directement commencé à
vaciller plusieurs coups de poing au
niveau de l'abdomen
j'ai sans se répéter à quatre ou cinq
reprises les mois ce nombre à genoux jim
et mahdia s'arrête là c'est fini pour
moi je vais mourir
j'ai suivi leur la saint georges frêche
je me dis en fait là si je peux mourir
d'instruction aujourd'hui chargée
d'affaires également cédric joue bien à
la sauce et se livrèrent sur moment de
la fouille que les choses les choses
vont aller encore plus loin
vous enlevez vos vêtements quand vous
arrivez au commissariat j'arrive au
comptoir et 1 femme et en salle de
fouille avec les deux mêmes policiers
les mêmes policiers qui l'ont interpellé
je suis toujours avec eux et un mois ce
moment là j'enlève ma graisse mais riche
en entretien et pour ceux qui rentrent
et les policiers religieuses et morales
pour voir la fiche le tram ne mettrai
pas de soucis referme la porte
j'enlève mon pantalon mes chaussures au
moment du talent st ledger policiers
cinq cents ans dix ans que j'enlève mon
attention
les policiers me demande toujours
l'intention j'ai deux centrales sont en
ce moment là genre de deux policiers
tétouan accroupis toi et tous ce qui est
formellement interdit
à ce moment là j'ai premier police et il
pourra que faire le trajet en vue d'une
dictée sur une première fois j'ai écouté
sur me repose la question une deuxième
fois les chaussures à ce moment là à ce
moment là j'ai un policier qui se jette
sur moi qui le trompe vous notamment à
ce moment là j'étais impôts de ceux qui
disent non au niveau 2 les gens
l'étude donne des coups de poing qui
était ce vraiment violent j'avais la
respiration coupée
je vais le souffle coupé gt en caleçon
je recevais des coups de poing j'étais
tremblay à ce moment là j'ai pour ses
clients tels sont les quelques chaînes
attention à la tire locales sont
introduits l'entretien doit dans - tome
1 que j'étais viré il ne sut des badges
je pense que c'était vraiment de 65 ans
j'étais toujours n'est pas john f
il s'est arrêté deux agents pouvaient
plus de plus dépassé tout pour que ça se
passe bien je te verrai je te tabasse
je n'en pouvais plus et si la personne
qui intervenait à ce moment là gît au
sol et un policier qui sort son
téléphone et photographies il prend en
photo avec son téléphone alors que
j'étais
et puis saint jacques attali j'ai fait
tout ça depuis depuis seulement qui
court après un policier pour qu'il
manquait à ce moment là je suis traîné
puisque n'importe quelle autre il lui
l'auteur la salle de tri entre temps
c'est maintenant qu'elles font mais de
l'aveu de cette somme doit s'assurer
fini ce qu'ils vont faire
voilà gîte au sol annequin
j'avais la main droite noté quand je te
laisse à m
le témoignage de tommy est saisissant
c'est parce qu'on sent vraiment
l'émotion domine quand vous revivez la
scène on vous revivez un cauchemar on le
ressent les téléspectateurs aussi c'est
que je pense et c'est incroyable tommy
est aujourd'hui vous avez été vous êtes
relâché au bout de combien de temps ma
garde à vue prolongée de 24 heures
est ce que je demande l'audition chez
eux avec un avantage de medasys indiqué
l'avocat qu'ils ont été violés mais moi
ça me faisait mal va pas laisser pas mal
ma vente la oumma l'audition est bas
s'il gérait un hidjab seulement du fait
que l'observation il ça m'a vraiment
choquée et moi ce moment là dans
l'édition je souhaite pas pour autant de
faire des déclarations pour que les
magistrats sont avertis de ce qui
m'arrivait à ce moment la majorité j'ai
été violée toutefois les ong pour faire
du test
un homme pour trouver le viol vous avez
vous avez porté plainte aujourd'hui à
l'igpn comme je l'aï dit on en est ou de
l'enquète par les biens au micro
atomique s'cusez moi mathieu joue ses
sorties font entrer chez moi des sushis
moment matin je suis allé directement de
gpl audition qui a duré huit ans
chantera midi dans leurs locaux font
sorcier à 21h35 mata du public pour mes
pv d'audition c'était 13h15 les 21h35
pour la fin depuis j'attends des
réponses de la porte de villepin et vous
avez des nouvelles de l'anc est obligée
aucune vision tout nouvel avocat john
dowd aussi ne suscite pas vraiment ma
salive dans certains cas on va on va on
va essayer de voir ce qu'on peut faire
est d'essayer de se renseigner sur ce
dossier auprès du gpn et doivent savoir
où ça en est tommy on va vous tenir bien
entendu au courant
aujourd'hui vous arrivez à revivre
normalement j'ai l'impression que vous
êtes vraiment brisé le 12 gw au delà de
sa psychologie
je ne veux pas mais je veux travailler
toujours travailler ou chercheurs
d'emploi n'a aujourd'hui vous êtes
psychologiquement voilà on vous sent
vraiment c'est très très marquée brisé
cyclos dimanche et détruites avant
d'aller aux toilettes des moutons nous
toucher
aujourd'hui vous avez envie que justice
soit faite c'est ça c'est ça qui vous
permettrait une dinde voilà deux essais
ou ça vous reviendra jamais en arrière
mais essayer de revivre normalement mon
ski j'ai mûri au le pain c'est que nous
tous ici dans un premier temps sur six
cas qui nous occupe au skate cinq films
ce qui va arriver
cependant au moins que ceux des
policiers sont dans un véhicule de
police en train de poindre au moment du
tri je peux pas je n'arrive pas à dormir
et donc les gpn ça fait qu'on attende
n'avait pas de nouvelles enquêtes de
semaine en semaine en semaine
ok on va voir on va essayer de se
renseigner tommy je voudrais vous
remercier pour votre témoignage qui a
été très très fort ce soir on va essayer
de faire le maximum pour avoir la
lumière sur cette affaire
on aura bien entendu je pense dans les
prochains jours à la version a également
des policiers c'est ce qu'on fait à
chaque fois parce que tu y parviens
tenue bien sûr par le csa aussi d'avoir
les deux versions quand on peut donc on
va inviter des personnes de ce
commissariat pour avoir la vérité leur
vérité on a eu la bonne
en tout cas votre témoignage était très
fort et on va essayer d'avoir des
nouvelles
essayer de voir s'il enquête avance
c'est tout le monde depuis deux pas
je demande tout au moment du demandeur
lopy comme j'ai vous avez toujours dit
j'ai tout fourni je ne pense pas sauf
s'est jamais fait cas des hôpitaux ida
ils allaient dans les terrains où tous
ces panneaux et pour ça j'ai ainsi
guillaume en personne par an à votre
famille justement il se sent qu'ils
jouent
ces plaisirs de perdre des pères de
famille d'un verre de famille c'est moi
ou gens vivent dans l'anonymat est
protégé le carat et par peur des
policiers
c'est à dire que dites vous moi je suis
ici devant vous j'étais aujourd'hui le
temps le savent pas c'est à dire qu'il
s'est petitement de votre envoi
aujourd'hui c'est tout ce qui figure il
voulait qu'on passe qui vous protège
parce qu'il a peur sans vie parce que la
peur de votre image moi à la base
j'étais plus jeune j'étais spectateur
était spectateur de te plaît jamais un
jour ma vie je me suis dit d'autres
disent maintenant dans une autre
situation ne pas d'un seulement permis
en tout cas ça fait très plaisir moi que
voilà que vous ne sauriez mais n'aura
pas donc c'est clair qu'on va essayer de
remercier de faire quelque chose pour
vous comme on essaie de faire à chaque
fois on est et on est très touché 1 par
ray moines à son sens extrêmement
sincère je vous le dis à tommy et on va
tout faire pour que la lumière soit
faite sur cette affaire
tommy merci en tout cas et j'espère
qu'on verra dans d'autres conditions
vous les deux bientôt merci tommy
[Applaudissements]